هل هناك اي تنازلات محتمله لانه في الوقت
الراهن يقول القطريون ان المطالب غير
معقوله هل من غير المنطقي مطالبه القطريين
بوقف تمويل الارهاب والتطرف هذا بحد ذاته
هو رد غير معقول جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
لديها تاريخ معين في منطقتنا وتعتبر منظمه
ارهابيه من قبل حكومات متعدده في المنطقه
وفي الخارج على سبيل المثال روسيا سبقتنا
بتصنيفها منظمه ارهابيه في 2006 لذلك
الامر ليس واضحا بشكل قاطع حول ما اذا
كانت ببساطه حزبا سياسيا او حركه سياسيه
انها منظمه اشبه بطائف دينيه لا تزال توقر
اشخاصا مثل سير قط الذي هو ابو العنف
المتطرف في
منطقتنا اخبرني عن هذا الموعد النهائي
سلمت المطالب منذ خمسه ايام مضت بمهل عشره
ايام هل نتحدث اذا عن الاثنين المقبل وهل
هناك وقت محدد وماذا يحدث بعد
ذلك مما فهمته ستنتهي المهله في الثالث من
يوليو وهو موعد نهائي لتحديد هدف نعمل
نحوه لم يرد القطريون حتى الان على اي من
مطالبنا ولم يعطونا اجابات واضحه حسب ما
راينا ولذلك نحن ننتظر بصبر لنرى ماذا
سيقولون ماذا تعتقد سيكون الاجراء المقبل
في حال رفض القطريون الامتثال لما يقولون
انها مطالب غير
معقوله اعتقد انكم لن تروا اي رد فعل على
الاطلاق سنجتمع كلنا ونجلس للتفكير في
الخطوات القادمه المناسبه هذا ليس امرا
خطط له بشكل جيد بمعنى اننا ننوي تدمير
قطر او ايذاء قطر باي شكل من الاشكال
وانما في الواقع لطالما كنا نامل ان تاتي
الى الطاوله وتقول انظروا وافقنا على
سلسله من المبادئ المحدده في 2014 ووقع
حاكم قطر تلك الاتفاقيه معترفا بانه كانت
هناك اخطاء في الماضي وان الجزيره دعمت
التطرف كما دعمت الحكومه القطريه ايضا
الحركات المتطرفه وانهم سياخذ خطوه للوراء
لذلك السؤال هو هل سيستطيعون التقدم الان
وقول نعم نوافق الان على اليه دوليه لنبدا
فعليا بالسيطره على هذه القضيه